this is the exact same problem that I
did in the last video but I realized
after looking at the problem that I just
mindlessly did the problem but there's
actually a much simpler way of doing it
so once again they're telling us to
subtract and state the difference in
simplest form what I did in the last
video was I just said okay let's find a
common denominator and then I found it
and then I did the subtraction but what
I could have done and that would have
simplified all of the math is I could
have simplified each of these
expressions first so let's do that
so this first expression right over here
both the numerator and the denominator
is divisible by M so let's divide them
both by M if you divide the numerator by
M you get 1 you divide the denominator
by M M squared divided by M is just M
the second term right over here both of
them both the numerator and the
denominator are divisible by n to the
third power so let's divide the
numerator by n to the third power you
get a 1 you divide the denominator you
divide n to the fourth by end of the 3rd
power you just get an N and so we can
rewrite this as 6 over 6 times 1 so
that's just 6 6 over 7m n minus 5
because that's just 5 times 1 over 3m
and and this really simplifies the
problem
so what's let's think about a common
denominator over here so it's gonna be
something minus something so a common
denominator has to be divisible by both
7 and 3 so the least common multiple of
7 and 3 is 21 and it has to be divisible
by M and has to be divisible by n 21 MN
and that also takes care of this 21 MN
is clearly divisible by 7 MN and it's
clearly divisible by 3 MN it's got the
MN there it's divisible by 3 is
divisible by 7 so that's our least
common multiple or you could say it's
our common denominator and to get from
7mn to 21 MN you got to multiply by 3
and if you're multiplying the
denominator by 3 you got to multiply the
numerator by 3 and you get 3 times 6 is
equal to 18 and to go from 3 MN - 21 MN
you got to multiply by 7 I'll do it over
here you got to multiply it by 7 and if
you multiply the denominator by 7
you got to multiply the numerator by 7
if you don't want to change the value
you of the expression so five times
seven is is equal to 35 and then so this
is going to be equal to 18 minus 35
since we have this let me write it down
we have a common denominator here of 21
MN and we're gonna have to calculate 18
minus 35 in the numerator
I'll just write it over here 18 minus 35
in the numerator and 18 minus 35 is
negative 17 so we get negative 17 in the
numerator over 21 MN and we are done and
I think that was a good bit simpler than
the way we did it in the last video